جزيره بعيده عاش اهلها في هدوء واطمئنان
قناعتهم ورضاهم بحياتهم البسيطه كانت
مضربا للمثل الى ان فتحت لهم ابواب الثراء
على مسرحيها لتشهد واحده من اكثر القصص
عبره في بناء المجتمعات انها جزيره ناورو
رحله التحول من بلد للاثرياء الى مستنقع
للفقراء
[موسيقى]
تقع جزيره ناورو في جنوب غربي المحيط
الهندي مساحتها لا تتعدى الواحد والعشرين
كيلو مترا مربعا لذا فهي تعتبر اصغر دوله
في تلك المنطقه وثالثه اصغر دوله في
العالم وسكانها لا يتعدون العشره الاف
نسمه عام
1968 نالت هذه الجزيره استقلالها من
بريطانيا
امتلكت جزيره ناورو اكبر مناجم الفوسفات
في العالم واصبحت مقصدا لعدد كبير من
الاثرياء واصحاب الاموال فتحولت الى جنه
لسكانها فلا حاجه للعمل مع ارباح شهريه
تصل الى جيوبهم من بيع الفوسفات واعمال
التنقيب عنها واستخراجها عهدت الى عماله
من الخارج والخدمات اصبحت مجانيه والغيت
جميع الضرائب
بلغ اقتصاد جزيره ناورودور في منتصف
السبعينيات القرن العشرين حيث قدر نصيب
الفرد من الناتج الاجمالي المحلي بخمسين
الف دولار امريكي
البذخ انتشر في كل ارجاء الجزيره سيارات
فارهه ومنازل فخمه ونواد ليليه وينبوع
دافئ من النقود فجر لاهلها لدرجه انه
عندما كانت تتعطل سياره لاحدهم يرميها في
مياه المحيط ويتوجه الى استراليا ليشتري
غيرها كل ذلك تحت قياده الحاكم الفاركوش
البارون واكا الذي يضحك دائما بدون سبب
ويقضي اوقاته في الاحتفال مع سكان الجزيره
لكن ذلك الوضع لم يدم طويلا فسرعان ما
ضربهم الفقر والمرض نتيجه سياستهم
الاقتصاديه الفاشله فالحكومه هناك كانت
تنفق مبالغ طائله على مشروعات فاشله منيت
بخسائر فادحه ولم تدرك ان مخزون الفوسفات
سينفذ يوما ما وهو ما حدث بالفعل وضعت
ماوروفي مازق لا تحسد عليه لدرجه ان
استراليا تدخلت وقتها بما عرف باسم عمليه
الحل الهادئ
عمليه الحل الهادئ كانت تقضي بتخلص
استراليا من اللاجئين وارسال بضع مئات من
اللاجئين والباكستانيين الى مراكز
الاحتجاز في ناورو في المقابل وافقت
استراليا على انقاذ نورو من الوضع
الاقتصادي
ومساعدتها ماليا
الفقر ضرب الجميع فبعد نمط الحياه الباذخ
لم يكن احد معتادا على العمل او التجاره
وفي غضون عقود قليله ارتفعت نسبه البطاله
الى 90% واصبح نحو 97% من سكان الجزيره
مصابين بالسكر الذي تسبب في موت الكثير
منهم واضطر سكانها الى العوده للصيد حتى
يتمكنوا من مواصله حياتهم لتبقى الجزيره
مضرب مثل لسوء استغلال الموارد والاموال
[موسيقى]